everything is awesome everything is cool
when we finally see the second lego
movie early 2019 will see the release of
the sequel of the popular lego movie so
it's time we get to know it's voice
actors now let's check out the cast of
lego - Margot Robbie Gus - Margot Robbie
will be playing hi boy Harlequin that's
right it's Harlequin
the Internet's actually buzzing over the
rumors about harley quinn getting her
own movie but before that we'll see her
in the lego movie - Margot is known for
her role as Harley Quinn in the Suicide
Squad
but unfortunately the role left a sour
taste in people's mouths but everyone's
hoping Margot Robbie will make a better
impression in the lego movie instead
Margot has had a pretty impressive
acting career in just a short amount of
time the Hollywood actress said she's
actually addicted to fear she loves
being afraid and still trying out
whatever she's scared of it's what got
her some of the biggest roles ever it's
quite surprising to see that Margot
actually looks a lot different from her
Harley Quinn character a YouTube channel
called ace published an interview where
Margot discusses her role as Harley
Quinn just look at how adorable she is
and the backstory stuff though it's like
magic as of December 2018 Margot has
more than 10 upcoming movies list earned
her IMDB page which means that this
talented actress will have a very busy
schedule ahead and a lot of her projects
revolved around Harley Quinn which makes
us that much more excited evening news
will be in the front page Alison Brie
the next in line is Alison Brie who also
played unikitty in the first movie of
course she's getting the chance to do it
again in the second you might know
Alison from a popular show called Mad
Men where she portrayed a character that
goes through a very complicated
relationship there's no way for me to
escape to not be an object of pity white
she's also known for her role as Annie
Edison on community so you know she
leads a pretty busy Hollywood life
Alison is actually super fun off screen
here she is in an interview with Chris
Ferguson being incredibly goofy like
this drums of drums play the drums I do
the guitar we just love how versatile
she is in case you don't know how unique
it e looks like here's a little sneak
peek taken directly from the first movie
shoot play since we have a lot in common
and they definitely do have a lot in
common there's no denying that Alison is
incredibly talented but did you know
that she got a call from Steven
Spielberg himself who personally invited
her to play the role in a movie called
the post now that's quite an
extraordinary honor isn't it Chris Pratt
and who could possibly forget about
Chris Pratt he's by far one of the most
popular Hollywood actor ever how could
you not love him he has a fantastic
sense of humor and of course an even
better acting talent seriously
Entertainment tonight's posted a
behind-the-scenes video of him dancing
and it's just an absolute must see in
the second lego movie he's actually
realizing his role as the one and only
emmet brickowski and honestly he's
absolutely perfect for this role a
YouTube channel Joe Blow movie trailers
posted an official behind-the-scenes
footage of Chris bringing Emmet to life
with his voice hey when do I start
learning to become a master builder
again of course Chris has had many
iconic Hollywood roles over the years
including playing the amazing Andy Dwyer
in Parks and Recreation and let's not
forget about the fact that he has an
absolutely amazing friendship chemistry
with Jennifer Lawrence the two were
filming the passengers together and what
came out of it was endless
behind-the-scenes entertainment YouTube
channel [ __ ] strike found this gym and
one of their interviews sorry
let's be honest the second lego movie
would not be complete without Chris
Pratt playing in it brickowski Elizabeth
Banks the lego - movie is honestly full
of amazing actors so of course it also
has Elizabeth Banks from playing avery
jessup on 30 rock to the absolutely
iconic role of Effie in The Hunger Games
pass the marmalade that is mahogany
Elizabeth has been around for quite a
while
honestly who could possibly forget about
that is mahogany line but it's not the
only time Elizabeth proved to be a
talented actress Modern Family fans also
recognize her as sow and she also made
an appearance in pitch perfect 3 as Gael
every person here they've touched me
John well everyone has touched you
honestly
Gail deserved better in that movie
didn't she it's safe to say that
elizabeth has had a pretty busy
Hollywood career in the second lego
movie Elizabeth is a typical
tough-as-nails character who actually
has a good heart and is very caring to
those who are close to her but you can
drop the academia school but Elizabeth's
lego movie role isn't the only one role
you should be excited about by the looks
of it a Charlie's Angels reboot is
coming and Elizabeth is reportedly
playing the one and only Bosley we are
excited to see Elizabeth star in even
more movies in 2019
Channing Tatum hahaha where do we begin
with Channing Tatum the gorgeous
Hollywood actor has been making waves
ever since playing Duke on she's the man
and of course Tyler on the iconic movie
step up
[Music]
Channing's character is brand new to the
lego movie but not brand-new to anyone
else he's playing Superman if this
doesn't make you excited about the lego
movie and we're not sure what will of
course people also know Channing from
Magic Mike XXL which only proves that
this man can pretty much do anything
endless entertainment is definitely
guaranteed with this dance man YouTube
channel of Channing having fun with his
Magic Mike XXL castmates
[Laughter]
honestly this guy just looks like he's a
ton of fun to be around as of December
2018 Channing is actually dating the
UK's very own Jessie J so it's safe to
say he's off the market guess we'll just
have to enjoy watching him on the big
screen and hearing his voice in the new
lego movie and we'll take what we can
get won't we Stephanie Beatrice Brooklyn
nine-nine fans already knows Stephanie
for arguably playing one of the best
characters on the show Rosa Diaz really
has it all doesn't she how many guns do
I still have hidden no do I saw my knife
nunchucks axe but you might be surprised
when you learn that Stephanie is nothing
like her Rosa character her voice is
actually completely normal and nowhere
near as dark which just proves how
talented she is check out in GL Studios
productions YouTube clips showing what
she actually looks like and I'm Stefanie
Beatrice were from a TV show called
Brooklyn nine-nine Stephanie will be
playing sweet ma'am in the new lego
movie although her acting resume is very
short she's had some surprising roles in
case her voice sounds familiar
but you're not sure where else to put it
you might want to re-watch Ice Age
collision course where she plays dirty
pop I hate to say this but my freaky
little brother may be right seriously
this talented lady is totally versatile
and it's crazy to see how she can change
her voice just like that make sure to
let us know in the comments if you
prefer Stephanie with her Rosa Diaz
voice or her normal voice you just know
the lego movie will be good
if it has Stephanie Beatrice in it
though Jonah Hill Jonah Hill is an
excellent addition to the lego movie
cast because let's be honest no one else
could play the Green Lantern as well as
him Superman Lantern Green Lantern of
course we saw Green Lantern in the first
movie as well as the Lego Batman movie
so it's no surprise that he's back once
again don' has had a pretty impressive
acting career before his role you could
see him in wolf of wallstreet 21 Jump
Street and How to Train Your Dragon yeah
my wife yeah Mike was my cousin he's an
absolutely hilarious actor so it's no
wonder he's returning for the second
lego movie Jonah has had minor roles in
popular movies such as Evan Almighty
forgetting sarah marshall and even click
with Adam Sandler he's definitely proven
he can play just about any role there is
but let's be honest Green Lantern is
pretty amazing and for glad he's back
for the second movie he's just one of
those actors that makes movies a million
times better with his cameos as well as
main roles who doesn't love Jonah Hill
he's completely awesome
Nick Offerman Chris Pratt isn't the only
star from Parks and Recreation that will
be in the new lego movie Nick Offerman
the man who played the hilarious Ron
Swanson is plain metal beard of once
again and honestly that is the most
perfect character name for this
hilarious dude the name be metal beard
and I'll tell you a me too Nick actually
has his own YouTube channel called my
tales of whiskey official if you didn't
think he was funny just yet this YouTube
channel will make you laugh out loud
Nick actually drinks whiskey for 45
minutes straight without saying a word
honestly this is actual art
it's like one of those meditation videos
of people just sitting there for hours
but with whiskey of course something
like this could only come from a
hilarious person like Nick scream slam
YouTube channel actually showed a clip
of Nick filming the first lego movie and
it's pretty amazing
this is ridiculous if you'd listened to
me we'd be sailing along happiest cheese
honestly Nick makes any movie just a
million times better with his awesome
sense of humor welcome back medal beard
his IMDB page shows that Nick will also
be playing metal beard in a short movie
called the lego movie masters of flight
and we bet that's not even the last
we'll see of metal beard or Nick Tiffany
Haddish people got pretty excited when
they heard Tiffany Haddish will be in
the second lego movie she's one of the
few cast members on this list that
hasn't had a character in the first
movie at all her character's name will
be queen whatever 1.avi and we have a
feeling she'll be completely glorious
tiffany is mostly known for her acting
and writing on the popular movie girls
trip girls chip was actually so
successful Tiffany won a Primetime Emmy
which is pretty amazing we can wait to
see what this new characters role will
be like in the new lego movie Tiffany is
actually pretty hilarious if you haven't
seen any of her stand-up comedy you
absolutely have to check it out a
YouTube channel called the Laugh Factory
has shown a compilation of her
performances it stated that she's been
performing stand-up comedy there since
she was a teenager which is pretty
amazing amber and Samantha although to
give you a bit of a warning Tiffany's
comedy is definitely not aimed at a
pg-13 crowd but we're certain it will be
in the new lego movie Charlie Day
seriously this movie has so many iconic
characters Charlie Day is probably best
known for his role as Charlie Kelly in
its Always Sunny in Philadelphia you
pour gas in the car
these funnels right and I count how much
gas is going into the court
honestly the second lego movie has a ton
of hilarious actors and actresses in
fact there's no one on our list that's
not actually funny charlie is reprising
his role as Vinnie the always happy
spaceman and honestly this role totally
suits Charlie Day Charlie of course
still can't believe the success It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia had 13
seasons later it's pretty phenomenal but
we do love that he also takes the time
to take on other roles and not just
roles he also makes pretty hilarious
YouTube appearances check out this
hilarious clip from first we feast
YouTube channel where Charlie takes on
spicy wings starting to feel like [ __ ]
charlie is actually one of the few
people that has always had a steady job
to come back to since it's always sunny
has had such an amazing run it's a job
security many Hollywood actors could
only dream up but nevertheless we have a
feeling his career will be safe even
after it's always sunny has had its
final run after all that's what Charlie
deserves doesn't do but wait we're not
done yet with our behind the mic video
there's one last actor you'll see in the
new lego movie and he's probably playing
the most important role ever Will Arnett
if we're talking about iconic stars from
shows like It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia and Parks and Recreation we
also have to mention our wrested
development and with Arrested
Development comes
Will Arnett dramatically hurled the
letter into the sea
we told you this movie is full of
amazing comedians so you know it's going
to be awesome
will is of course playing Batman and he
was in the first movie and honestly he
did a pretty good job but a LEGO version
of Batman is not all will is known for
he's also played Vernon on Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles and has an
extensive acting resume with plenty of
other roles including Jack on Sex in the
City the list goes on and on seriously
this guy is absolutely amazing so it's
only fair to have him return for the
second lego movie YouTube channel GQ
posted a video of will give him a
lowdown on his most iconic characters
and honestly his list is pretty
impressive I feel like we really kind of
found our groove in this video we'll
also talks about how we started doing
indie movies when he was up-and-coming
in Hollywood but quickly realized that
it's not enough to favor his rent this
is most likely true for most actors
after all being a Hollywood star is a
tough job but it pays off when you get
to do movies like the lego - the second
part movie be honest are you excited for
the second lego movie or are you kind of
over it all let us know in the comments
below and that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things for
more feel-good content thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]